Today's video is sponsored
by War Thunder.
Today, we're putting a common
household hazard to the test.
We are going to see what happens
if you stick a paperclip
into a live outlet.
[Music]
Here, we have an outlet,
and of course, normally,
outlets aren't just sitting
in the middle of desk.
But this outlet has been
extended from the wall outlet.
This is a normal outlet.
It has all the same insides
and parts and workings and wires
as the outlets in your wall.
The only difference is it's
a lot easier to get
to here on the desk.
As you can see,
Calli has plugged
in this lamp,
and it is functioning.
Of course, it's also not normal
for a tank to come crashing
through your wall,
but that's something you can do
in the game War Thunder,
our sponsor for today's video.
Nate and I had a chance to try
out this online military
vehicle combat game,
and it's a lot of fun.
It's true.
We were able to download it
for free on our computers,
but you can also play it
for free on Xbox and PS4,
and if you want
to play with friends,
but don't have
the same system,
that's all right,
because War Thunder allows
for cross-platform play.
Something that I
thought was really cool
about this game too is
that this game has
more than 1,200 historically
accurate playable tanks,
aircraft, helicopters, ships,
everything ranging
from the 1930s to the 1990s.
Personally, I like
playing the M1 A1 Abrams.
It's just amazing to drive
around this vehicle
that you see in today's news.
Click the link
in the description to register
and download War
Thunder for free.
By using our link,
you will receive
a premium tank or aircraft,
as well as three days
of premium account time.
So let's take a look at
what's inside an outlet.
And again, this
is the same thing
that's going on
inside your wall.
This is just kind of
a slick little packaging for it.
Other than that,
it's exactly the same.
So you can see
that the three wires
here actually connect
with the three different
parts of the socket.
So you've actually got
a ground, a neutral,
and a hot,
and they all connect
with the different wires.
In the United States,
ground is either going
to be bare copper,
or with a green
covering over it.
Neutral is white,
and the hot wire,
the one where electricity
comes in, is black.
Those connect onto our outlet.
Usually, in an outlet
in the United States,
where you attach the hot wires
is going to have gold screws,
and where you attach
the neutral wire is going
to have silver screws.
In this case,
they've also used
a green screw to show
where the ground attaches.
The ground is
an emergency backup wire.
It's in case
something goes wrong.
If too much
electricity flows through,
or if something
gets physically broken,
the ground is there
to make sure that
any wire flowing
through the hot get sent
into the safe ground spot,
because it's not going
to be flowing correctly
through the neutral wire.
So now, you've seen
what's inside the outlet.
We have the three different
wires that each corresponds
to the three holes
in the plug face.
This bottom one
that's shaped kind
of like an archway,
that's the ground wire.
All of the electricity is coming
in through the hot wire.
That's the smaller
hole on the right.
The other two holes are
the neutral and the ground,
and that's where
the electricity goes back out.
To get alternating
current to work,
it needs to be
completing this path,
and it only comes from one side
and goes out the other side.
So now, we want to find out
exactly what's going to happen
if we start sticking bits
of metal into our outlet.
Here's the basic idea.
We have got paper clips,
we've got knives,
and we've got electricity.
Let's see what happens
when they all meet.
We've got a voltmeter,
and we can use it
to test the voltage
running through this outlet.
We'll attach one lead
into the hot and one lead
into the neutral,
and then, we can also
attach to the ground,
and we should get
the same result.
We're seeing about 122.9,
and we are in the United States,
where usually that's
putting out about 120.
So that lines up pretty nicely.
If a person were
to get 15 amps running
through them at 120 volts,
that could stop your heart.
It's really, actually,
a dangerous amount
of electricity.
So, is this something
that can happen to you just
by sticking a paperclip
in the outlet?
So, in the neutral,
we get a reading of 123.
If we put the lead
in the ground,
the exact same
reading, 123 volts.
Is a paperclip going
to complete a circuit?
Well, it's possible.
Here's the thing you
have to keep in mind.
If the paper clip is
in the hot side of the outlet,
there is electricity
flowing into it,
but electricity isn't
going to flow
unless it can go somewhere.
With a neutral and ground,
that allows the
circuit to complete.
If the paperclip
is touching nothing,
then a circuit
is not going anywhere.
It's not complete,
and electricity is not going
to flow through it.
However, you could be grounded.
Currently, I'm wearing
shoes with rubber soles
and rubber gloves,
but they are kind of
thin rubber gloves,
and I don't know exactly
how conductive my shoes are.
So it's possible
that if I put this
into the hot side of the outlet,
it would zap me.
Although, I do feel fairly safe
putting it into the neutral
and the ground side,
and I'm even gonna try
that right now.
It doesn't seem to be
doing anything to me.
I'm not feeling it.
Ground.
Neutral.
Nothing's really
happening there.
With the outlet unplugged,
we've now fit this paper clip
into the hot side,
and now, we're going
to plug it back in,
and do some more testing on it.
Not by grabbing it though.
Let's take our voltmeter,
and check this again.
So again, we're going to have
one connected to the neutral,
and the other one,
we're going to touch
to our paper clip,
which is now extended out.
So this paper clip is now hot.
And by hot, I don't mean
temperature, it's warm.
I mean, that it has electricity
ready to flow right through it.
123 flowing through
that paper cup right there.
Now, I'm not quite dumb
enough to just grab
straight on to that,
but we have some hot dogs,
which have a similar moisture
and sodium content to people.
And we're going
to see what happens
if we connect hot dogs
to both of these wires.
So, he's putting
on a much thicker,
much more insulated
gloves for this.
Okay.
So now, we're going to see
if anything happens
with this hot dog touching
to both of these paper clips.
Oh!
That is sparking
and that is burning.
Yeah, I don't know
about, you guys,
but I like my fingers
more than that.
So that would,
that would be
your fingers right there.
Yeah, it almost has
a smell of burning hair.
That's actually what
this reminds of.
Probably the casing
around the hot dog.
So, you may see this
and think well, I mean,
I get that it's shocking
and it's burning a little bit,
but that doesn't look
like that bad of an injury.
So, if you just left
a hot dog sitting
on this for like 10 minutes,
would you have a cooked hot dog?
At least, partially.
Right now, we've got
the lead so close together
that they're not going
to cook most of the hot dog.
It's just going to travel
the shortest path from
where it's touching.
But now, I'm going
to see what happens
if I actually try and to stab it
onto the paper clips.
[Music]
>> I think--
>> Yeah...
I don't think you want
that on your skin.
I think you made it angry.
Oh, boy.
Did I ever?
Oh, no.
That smells awful.
Okay, that's not the smell
of burning meat, guys.
That smell of like melting
acrylic and burned hair.
That's terrible.
This like carved a hole
into the hot dog,
and completely blackened
out that paper clip.
So with the hot dogs,
it just takes
a little bit of contact,
and you can see
it starts burning.
However, there is
a bigger concern with people.
When electricity flows
through muscles on a person,
they actually are activated.
They seized up,
and they contract.
Hot dogs don't have a lot
of muscles going on in them.
In fact, I'd go
ahead and say no...
None muscle.
No connected, active muscles
inside a hot dog.
People, however,
are full of them,
and it takes only as
little as 0.005 of a volt to
make the muscles start spasming.
This is much more than that.
This is 120,
about 123, actually,
volts running through this.
So, if you were
to accidentally touch this,
then your muscles
could seize up, grab
the paper clips even harder,
and maybe pull you in
so that you can't let go,
and then the electricity
keeps flowing through you
with no other path.
It's just going to go
through you until something
breaks that circuit.
So, we've seen
what our finger analog does
if it comes in contact
with both the hot and the
neutral leads at the same time.
All right, so I want us to try
and actually bend one
of these paper clips,
and see if we
can complete that circuit
without using a second one.
When I say "we",
I meant I was going
to make Nate do it.
Now, I'm going to be wearing
a thick rubber glove,
I have rubber-soled shoes,
and the paperclip should conduct
electricity very well.
So this paper clip will be
the path of least resistance.
This should mean
that electricity isn't flowing
into me, especially,
because this is a pretty good,
sturdy rubber glove,
and I really think
it's going to do a good job.
Let's plug this in,
and see what a paperclip does
in the hot and neutral.
Well, definitely,
got a lot of sparks out of that.
Well...
Got a lot
more sparks out of that.
You were making...
Wow!
>> That went--
>> Staying very connected.
Oh, did the light turn off?
Oh, the light just turned off.
Okay, so we had lights plugged
in all around the studio,
and that second time there
where it sparked,
they all turned off.
So I'm pretty sure that means
we've now tripped the breaker,
which is what we
were hoping would happen.
That's what the breaker
is designed for.
And you can see now,
this is still in there,
and nothing's happening,
no more sparks, it's not hot,
and all the lights are off.
So, we need to find
the circuit breaker.
Should be this switch.
You can see how this,
for example, this doesn't move
that direction at all.
This one however,
can click that way.
That means it's tripped.
So what we do is
we switch it back to off,
and then the paper clip is
not in there anymore, is it?
Nope.
I'm checking.
You're good.
That should have fixed it.
We've got our outlet unplugged
again after successfully
tripping the breaker
with our paper clip
a couple of times.
The next thing we're going
to try is fitting our paper clip
into the hot lead side
of the outlet,
and then, touching it
to the grounded screw
in the middle of the outlet.
We're going to see if we get
the same reaction to that
as we did with the neutral
side of the outlet.
Yep.
That tripped the breaker again.
Whoo.
Wow.
Yep.
That zaps it pretty good.
There's just burn marks all
around the screw now.
Something that I
think is important to note.
When we had the paperclip
connecting the circuit,
it sparked a lot,
but the breaker tripped,
it turned off.
When we had the hot dog
connecting the two paper clips,
it wasn't flowing enough
to trip the breaker.
That's probably the same thing
that would happen
with your fingers.
The electricity would flow,
it would burn,
it would cause your muscles
to contract and seize,
but it probably isn't going
to trip the breaker,
which means...
>> It's gonna keep hurting.
>> You're in trouble.
Yeah, it's gonna keep going.
You've heard the story
of the kid who puts a fork
in the socket and gets shocked.
So we've got a paperclip stuck
into the neutral side,
and we're going to do
some tests with a fork
and a couple of knives, and see
if we can complete
that circuit using those.
Right now, it's not plugged in,
but can a fork fit in there
enough to make contact
with the leads?
Or is it too big and broad?
How about the two
knives we've got?
We're going to try
it with all them.
Let's try butter knife first.
Well, first problem immediately,
and I don't think there's
any way to wiggle or fine angled
that into actually make it.
So let's try our fork next.
[Music]
I don't think
that's going to go either.
I don't think there's any way
to touch that hot wire.
Last utensil we're going to try,
I think we might have
some success with this one
given the angle.
You do jump.
I told you.
Look at that.
So this where the paperclip
touched our knife.
Zap.
So with this fork
and table knife,
it wouldn't fit into the outlet.
It would not.
So, I'm thinking
that this butter knife was
just too rounded to actually
touch the hot wire,
and for this fork,
those tines are just too thick.
I'm sure if somebody
was very determined
and had a thinner fork,
they could make it work.
This particular fork
is just very sturdy.
We want to be clear
that just because we
weren't able to fit this fork
and this knife in this outlet
does not mean it's safe.
It doesn't mean
you should try it.
You should not try to do it.
That's the whole point
we're trying to make.
We're not putting
this to the test
for you to put this to the test.
We're showing you
why not to do this.
Yeah.
So, what happens when you stick
a paper clip in an outlet?
Burns, shocks, sparks.
Tripping the breaker.
So overall, not a good plan,
but it's fun
to show what happens
because you always hear,
and now, you can see why
you don't want to do that.
Instead, if you want
to see something explode,
download War Thunder using our
link in the description below.
Remember that you can receive
a free bonus for registering,
a premium tanker,
aircraft, as well as three days
of premium account time.
This game is free to download,
and is available
on PC, Mac, PS4,
and Xbox One.
Guys, that's not all,
we've always got more
for you to see.
That box up at the top is going
to take you to our last video.
You should go check that out.
The other box
is going to show you
what YouTube thinks you
should be watching next.
We got this bomb
here in the middle.
You give that bad boy a click,
and you'll be subscribe
to our channel.
That way, you never miss
out on a cool video.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we'll see you
in the next one.
Talk to you then.